[Música]
la oposición ecuatoriana activó el
pedido de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso a quien
señalan de presunta corrupción y
malversación de fondos aún falta una
revisión de la corte constitucional que
Determine si esta denuncia está
debidamente fundamentada y es procedente
ampliamos desde quito
la temporada de lluvias en Perú ha
dejado cerca de 12.000 damnificados y
alrededor de 60 muertos en los últimos
días El paso del ciclón Jaco ha golpeado
varias zonas costeras del Norte y el
centro del país donde se mantienen las
inundaciones y deslizamientos
el gobierno de Argentina denunció
penalmente a los directivos de las
distribuidora eléctrica de sur El
documento Menciona los delitos de
malversación de fondos fraude en
perjuicio de la Administración pública y
abandono de persona debido a los
constantes apagones que viene afectando
al país en medio de una intensa ola de
calor
[Música]
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Ecuador donde la oposición activó el
proceso de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso a quien
señalan de proteger a personas cercanas
a él y al oficialismo en un presunto
entramado de corrupción en empresas
públicas previamente conversamos con
Gustavo Ortega corresponsal de France 24
en Quito que nos explicó qué pasos
siguen Y si ya es un hecho que habrá
juicio político
59 46 firmas requeridas para solicitar
formalmente el juicio político la
bancada de oposición ha presentado ante
la gestión documental de la asamblea
nacional el pedido para enjuiciar así el
presidente de la república presenta esta
solicitud de juicio político cuatro de
las cinco bancadas que hacen en vida en
la asamblea nacional el partido ures que
convoca a el correísmo el partido social
cristiano que eran antiguos aliados al
presidente de la república una fracción
del pachacútec el cual agrupa los
movimientos indígenas izquierda
democrática formalmente comienzan así lo
que es la solicitud de juicio político
contra presidente de la república
posteriormente Entonces qué es lo que va
a pasar será un hecho o no Bueno esto
debe cumplir con un procedimiento por
parte de la normativa legal del Ecuador
ya el presidente de la asamblea nacional
Virgilio tiene tres días para presentar
ante el órgano calificador de la
asamblea nacional este pedido de juicio
político ante este órgano calificador
que posteriormente debe revisar si
cumple con los requisitos de ley para
presentarlo ante la Corte constitucional
posteriormente entonces la corte
constitucional debe decidir en un
periodo de seis días Si cumple o no con
estos requisitos legales para indicar si
habrá o no un juicio político en total
de considerar positivos para comenzar
con juicio político el presidente de
república podría ser destituido por un
proceso que se extenderá por 55 días
pasamos a Perú donde la temporada de
lluvias ha dejado alrededor de 60
muertos y cerca de 12.000 damnificados
en los últimos días el ciclón yaku ha
provocado inundaciones y deslizamientos
de tierra obligando al gobierno a
declarar el estado de emergencia Alba
Santana nos amplía
agua y más agua escenarios como este han
marcado los últimos días de muchos
peruanos el ciclón yaku se saldó con
inundaciones acompañadas de fuertes
vientos a su paso que solo en la región
de Lima ya han dejado a más de tres mil
personas sin casa se se votó mi casa
nada más mis hijos también igual mis
nietos igual y como usted ve Ahora a
poder levantarme de nuevo pase de
trabajo pero con cubos algunos intentan
despejar las inundaciones para salvar
sus viviendas y pertenencias Y es que la
temporada de lluvias que comenzó en
septiembre ha causado muchos estragos en
el país sudamericano con decenas de
muertos y al menos 12.000 damnificados
han dicho defensa civil que tenemos que
subir por los que vivimos todos al
control del río para prevención porque
para que no nos pase ya nada los equipos
de rescate se han tenido que desplegar
en las zonas más afectadas y escenas
como esta
se han vuelto cada vez a más comunes
para intentar garantizar la seguridad de
la gente de la zona no tenemos nada como
perdimos todo absolutamente todo el
ciclón yaku denominado como no
organizado y estrechamente relacionado
con el fenómeno de la niña ha pillado
las autoridades a peruanas por sorpresa
y ha obligado al gobierno de Dina
boluarte a declarar estado de emergencia
en 400 distritos del país el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro informó que
ascendió a 21 el número de Mineros
fallecidos tras la explosión ocurrida la
noche del martes en seis minas de carbón
interconectadas en el centro del país de
esta manera las autoridades declararon
el fin de las labores de búsqueda y
rescate siete personas salieron por sus
propios medios y dos fueron rescatadas
con vida al momento de la emergencia
había 30 trabajadores en el interior de
Las Minas
el gobierno argentino presentó una
denuncia penal contra la compañía
eléctrica de Sur debido a la falta de
suministro que ha queja decenas de miles
de usuarios en Buenos Aires la portavoz
presidencial comunicó que en un plazo de
90 días estudiarán la posibilidad de
quitarle la concesión del servicio
Ramiro cuevalverena nos cuenta más
en medio de una ola de calor sin
precedentes y un aumento del descontento
social en Argentina el enre el ente
regulador de la electricidad denunció
penalmente a la empresa distribuidora de
energía edesur por pedido del gobierno
nacional luego de que decenas de miles
de usuarios se quedaran sin servicio en
el área metropolitana de Buenos Aires
algunos formas de una semana el gobierno
Está avanzando el Enrique fue
mandatado con la indicación de la
secretaria de energía del ministro de
economía para presentar hoy mismo con
las próximas horas una denuncia penal
contra el gerente general de la empresa
edesur y todos los miembros de su
directorio por malversación de fondos
fraude en perjuicio de la Administración
pública y abandono de personas el
gobierno también advirtió que evaluará
un informe del Henry y en los próximos
90 días estudiará la posibilidad de
revocar la concesión a la compañía
eléctrica por su parte los ciudadanos
continúan con sus reclamos mientras
crece la desesperación
es un lujo es un servicio esencial
tenemos la comida podrida dentro de las
heladeras del Freezer reclamas Sí pero
mientras tanto tenés que salir a comprar
agua tenés que salir a comprarle la
comida para el ratito ni siquiera para
el día para el ratito es hace un calor
desesperante Además del la ciudad de
Buenos Aires también ha presentado una
denuncia al igual que la localidad de
Esteban Echeverría que registró
problemas de operatividad en el hospital
municipal mientras que en otras ciudades
del sur de la provincia miles de
personas tampoco tienen agua potable
porque el funcionamiento de la empresa
encargada no tiene suministro eléctrico
el presidente de Chile Gabriel borics
anunció la creación de mar de pisagua
una nueva zona Marina protegida de
73.460 hectáreas el mandatario aseguró
que el área no sólo tiene que ver con el
futuro del país sino del mundo y busca
conservar y monitorear ecosistemas
acuáticos complejos en la región el jefe
de estado agregó que la zona permitirá
combinar actividades productivas
tradicionales como la pesca artesanal
con la producción de ecosistemas marinos
un grupo de bancos estadounidenses
financiaron millones de dólares a First
Republic Bank para rescatarlo de una
crisis provocada por el colapso de
silicon y signature Bank la semana
pasada el First Republic tuvo la tercera
tasa más alta de depósitos no asegurados
entre los bancos de Estados Unidos
solamente detrás de silicon Valley y el
signature según una nota de Raymond
James lo que hizo pensar a muchos que el
siguiente en la lista de quiebra sería
este banco desde Nueva York mamenza la
corresponsal de France 24 nos explicó
Cuáles bancos lo rescataron Y por qué
el principal motivo de este movimiento
ha sido Mostrar un sistema financiero
fuerte que respalda al pequeño y al
mediano banco y sobre todo que el
republican Bank no siguiera el mismo
camino que silicon o que signaturbank
aquí en Nueva York qué es lo que ha
ocurrido bien los 11 bancos 11 bancos
grandes bancos norteamericanos han
salido al rescate de public Bank que
estaba viendo cómo se quedaba sin
liquidez sus acciones a caían en picado
hasta un 70% Y ante esta situación han
salido a su rescate Con una inyección ha
sido una noticia que hemos conocido hoy
de 30.000 millones de dólares en
liquidez para estabilizarlo Cuáles son
los bancos que van a ayudar en esta
estabilización Pues bien el GP Morgan y
el banco famerica que ya han dicho que
ofrecerán una inyección de 5.000
millones de dólares el city bank
seguramente también es una información
Que de momento no está confirmada pero
algunos periódicos internacionales
apuntan a ello y el goldman sachs y
Morgan staline aportarían 2500 millones
de dólares una forma de mostrar unidad
fuerza y sobre todo apoyo a esos
pequeños bancos el ferre Republic Bank
no olvidemos que es una entidad
financiera regional pequeña no esto
contrasta mucho con la idea el mensaje
que está llegando por parte de la
secretaria del tesoro y por parte del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden que
siguen insistiendo en que la economía es
sólida y nadie nadie ninguna persona en
este país tiene sus ahorros en peligro
así que de momento la bolsa hoy ha
cerrado en números verdes muy pendientes
de cómo siguen esos futuros en sus
principales indicadores aquí en el
parque New yorkino a la espera de que
mañana vuelvan a abrir fin del
informativo gracias por su sintonía
[Música]